at her best but she is too sick to give
a talk today her throat's really sore
so she got so she won't be able to get
this love today Aviv has volunteered to
take this slot in the morning and I
think we'll actually have a nice program
the morning will be a talk on regulation
and taxation of cryptocurrencies in a
specific jurisdiction and then the after
the 11 o'clock slot will basically be a
workshop basically between the lawyers
in the room basically the lawyers in the
computer scientists will be a workshop
on functional equivalents basically
mapping legal concepts and constraints
to technical guarantees and I think that
will fit nicely after we learn about
some sort of some of the regulation
requirements here so that's that's the
morning program in the afternoon program
will basically involve Nils who couldn't
make it on Monday but will give a talk
today on he's from he's from Libra so
he'll talk about some of the economics
at Libra and then Rhys will basically
give the last talk which will be again
on regulation concept right that makes
you yes at 1:40 yeah yeah right so let's
let's welcome at the beep so I'm gonna
try to do something that's outside my
comfort zone
and I'm going to talk about regulation
for those who don't know me I'm a I'm a
computer scientist and so I should put
up you know this is since this is a
lawyer you talk I'm gonna put up the
disclaimer saying that I'm not a I - I'm
not a lawyer you know following others
they who came before me specifically I
think Kobe gave the best disclaimers so
what I want to talk about is kind of a
partial view of what goes on in Israel
and I'm qualifying this to Israel
because I'm not an international
regulation expert by any means with
regards to cryptocurrency regulation and
taxation and the reason I feel like I
can I can dare to give this talk is that
I had a lot of discussion with
regulators and others and we've been a
kind of hosting these events at the
Hebrew University under the
cybersecurity Center which is together
with the law department so I did get a
chance to interact with a lot of the a
lot of different interesting people who
are thinking about these problems and I
should also say that you know Israel is
by no means a place where regulation is
you know decided and later effect
anywhere else in the world but rather
the opposite
Israel will probably copy/paste
something from the US or Europe
eventually and so maybe this stock would
be a bit more applicable to other places
as well so maybe I should start with why
why I think we should care about about
regulation as a computer scientist and
then you know people who follow Bitcoin
and other cryptocurrencies so my
interest started because I kind of had
time to think about it and I think right
now regulation is by far the biggest
hurdle to to adoption of
cryptocurrencies and I was interested in
seeing why you know why this doesn't
happen and one of the major symptoms
that regulation or lack of regulation
causes is very high fees at exchanges so
every time you you have you know an
exchange fee of 5%
like in some of the Bitcoin exchanges in
Israel that's due to the fact that
they're waging very expensive legal
battles with with the state they have no
competition because everybody who sets
up in exchange in Israel has their bank
account closed after a few months so
this is this is really the reason
there's no competition and fees are not
going down and so people who feel the
volatility of Bitcoin you know could
have potentially escaped this volatility
by immediately selling everything right
and liquidating into dollars I think
when bitpay started for example there
was this hope that businesses will start
accepting Bitcoin payments which would
be instantly converted to US dollars and
it would be at a cost that's lower than
credit cards and that would be the kind
of a road to adoption and that
completely
failed and I think part of the reason is
is the fees could or could not be could
not be counted wrong because what's
prevents you from buying being in Israel
and to bein in the American exchange you
could have all your money abroad but
then you wouldn't be able to get back
into Israel if you ever wanted it again
I'll give you examples of specific
people who have a counsel broad have
sold bitcoins they have it in the back
of house abroad but they can't bring it
into Israel back so this is again white
specific maybe to Israel but I I heard
similar things are happening elsewhere
so you know the inability of people to
trade bitcoins which is kind of the use
case we move to after pretty much giving
up on on you know using Bitcoin for for
day-to-day trade and you know purchases
is also made very hard and I think one
of the like meta topics that this
teaches us is you know how regulation
and governments come to terms with with
basically disruptive new technology that
changes you know really foundational
things that matter to people
so I want to start with the maybe a
quick quick story that I heard from
somebody who's running a Bitcoin
exchange in Israel and I won't it's
gonna touch upon it basically a
technological mismatch something that we
could have easily solved but but it's an
unsolved in Bitcoin so I don't know if
you ever thought about it but there's
really no way to to send bitcoins and
Bitcoin payments back to sender but if
you get a Bitcoin payment from someone
it is a very very bad idea to reverse
the payment that send it to whoever sent
it to you it's just going to blow up in
your face
and this is because Bitcoin doesn't
really have a consistent notion of
address there are no Bitcoin addresses
really there's there are only Bitcoin
scripts right if you really think about
it could be that the so called address
you're receiving money from is not an
address it's just the hash of some
script right now or even if it is a
conventional address in the sense that
there's a public key associated with it
it could be maybe a large hot wallet of
an exchange and that guy has an account
within the exchange if you send money
back to their there they won't know to
associate it with the guy who sent it to
you there's just no way knowing that
this will be handled correctly
so we're living with this pretty well
because you know the script system also
allows us to do things in Bitcoin like
have layer two solutions on top of
Bitcoin so this is a nice benefit but I
want to show you like a very simple
scenario where this starts to become
problematic so generally though if you
sent me of image directly I could
conceivably just send it right like
create another transaction and send it
right back to you right so so wallets
after a while really quickly you know
try to to handle this well right I have
disposable addresses that I use only
once but I but the world still tries to
maintain your public key and and that
and tries to recover payments exactly if
that happens but if but usually people
nowadays you know hold money in
exchanges and send directly from there
so it's really risky to to return to
sender right right so there's a risk
involved in just like arbitrarily doing
it but technically yeah I mean if you
you and I talk and you say you just send
it back to the address obviously I can
do that practice is not to reuse an
address but right stopping it and in
fact the same person that the public you
can do the event that right that works
fine it's more like the infrastructure
problem of not being able to return
payments right yes and I'll show you
what exactly why you know I mean if you
think about it in regular conventional
banking you get a swift transfer from
someone there is a operation you know
your bank and say you know I don't want
to let you have that money because you
had a you know you're a fishy person and
maybe that came from a source that we
don't don't know and they can just
reverse the payment that's always
possible that's built into the Swift
system in this case right payments are
our push rather than right cooperative
and there's no way to return them
in every occurrence so here's the
scenario
an Israeli exchange receives bitcoins
that somebody wants to convert right
somebody opened the account and sent
them the bitcoins you know upon looking
at the Bitcoin payment some anti-money
laundering flag is raised you know maybe
it came out of a mixer suddenly they
found out they didn't know before and so
they don't want they don't want to
exchange the money yeah what is in
exchange it's it's a place that that
would sell you bitcoins in exchange for
shekels that's it
you you want bitcoins how do you get
them you've got you go to an exchange or
two right right I mean you could think
of two different things that I'm kind of
mashing together you could have a change
place that just you know change this
money and in exchange usually has is
more for trading this you could you
could put put bids in and limit orders
and so on but it's functionally you know
it's pretty much the same so some AML
flag is raised so they're supposed to
email anti money laundering
okay here's a lawyer eater my guess so
they they don't want to exchange the
money and and now they have a catch-22
okay they can't exchange the money and
give you the the shekels they're not
allowed to do this they can't keep the
funds because if they keep the funds you
know this is not their money it's
somebody else's money you can sue them
basically they can't send it back
they're sending it back that doesn't
always mean there's you know an address
there maybe it came out of an exchange
they can't reverse the payment and
they're they can't forward it to another
destination right if they ask you you
know where do you want it forwarded and
you give them an address maybe you just
gave them al-qaeda's
address and they just you know
unknowingly send money to al-qaeda you
know who knows they're in trouble so
they are sitting there you know thinking
well you know what what in God's name
are we gonna do with this money you know
we can't give it away we can't send it
back we're stuck all right so this is
this is a concern
technically yes sir send me money tell
KY yeah but it's not like they're like
you could have done that just as well
directly so it's not really something
that they're doing right
yeah but then this guy you know on the
other side you know on the al-qaeda side
right
somebody's gonna you know look at this
maybe it's another exchange it's an
account of al-qaeda at a decent exchange
and they're gonna ask you know where did
this come from and he's he's not gonna
be honest and say it came from the mixer
it came from the Israeli exchange and
they'll say okay these are you know
reputable guys and we know that they do
the path you can see the path but what
does that mean I mean so you're you're
you're assuming first that they will
send the exact same output that's
already a big assumption because it goes
into some wallet and then you know the
money that sent out is not necessarily
the thing that actually came in
exchanges don't manage money that way
you're also you're you're also assuming
that if you see a chain transfer it is
necessarily the same individual it could
be uh you know I paid you and you paid
up you know that that happens so what if
you trace it
the question is how far back do you need
to ask questions about money if you just
see something on chain
it's not annotated right currently you
could and as well soon talk about it
should be and I'll flag is raised on the
receipt of the transaction yeah some
some of these exchanges employ companies
like chain alysus that look at exactly
at the chain and they say okay this came
from a mixer we decide not to take the
risk
and we don't we just don't want to touch
this this is tainted you know this came
out of a Bitcoin theft that we've been
hurt we've been told about so when you
say when you come to them you say you
want you know I want to exchange twenty
thousand dollars at your exchange
they'll say sure but then you send the
money they say you okay that specific
Bitcoin you know we don't want to touch
those that that can happen
that's I think that's under there you
know the keeping it is also bad right
because this person can sue them here
right maybe it's not a real criminal
element and he might actually sue
further and for the funds so this is not
a story that I made up this is something
that a guy working anything Israeli
exchange for me you know we don't know
what to do the infrastructure right now
or in the best world is every Saturday
you know a transaction is from public
key to public key only that we don't
know who is this public key right now
but somebody will come and prove that
this is my public key will get the money
how no there's no original in
originating public key there is no
originating public key it may be the
public key that originated the
transaction is not his it's he can't
prove it he he sent it out of coinbase
the original public key is coin basis
coinbase will not necessarily agree to
take this money back you know how do you
contact them how do you know right
there's no infrastructure to do this
there's no way to do this systematically
right these guys don't don't want to
take care of each exception like this
you know one at a time they want a
system that would do it
so this is you know a very practical
thing and there's no technological
problem here per se right we could have
solved this easily in the protocol
design but it doesn't happen right so
this is right so this is by the way the
flavor of this talk you know regulation
is always about the nitty-gritty details
that are annoying and how laws are
currently written because we're not
going to change the laws just for this
case and we're not going to change the
Bitcoin protocol just for this and we're
stuck with you know with the
inconveniences like this so I guess
maybe you know when researchers meet
regulators we should be careful of these
famous last words you know how hard can
it be to get it right we'll see a lot of
cases where it kind of gets messy and
really what I found out about regulators
is that there are you know kind of
annoying for me they must work in the
current legal framework there are not
people who are legislators there
not thinking of how you know regulation
should be there there they're basically
they're technocrats you know they're
right now in the executive branch of the
government they're doing what needs to
be done so they will go to the letter of
the law because that's what they have
and they're also in a position where you
know people don't ask for their opinion
because you know the statement from a
regulator could be also may be
interpreted as the position of the
regulatory body which they are very
careful not to give so they don't
happily discuss hypotheticals if you
want to talk to them on the record the
they shy away from that a little bit
they want to prepare in advance they
want to run everything by their legal
departments so it's it was really hard
to have a conversation with them so we
had to kind of close all our discussions
and and especially because there were
court cases running as we were doing our
workshops in parallel in Israeli courts
about these matters so when you sell for
million dollars
some painting that says ok the buyer is
unknown because they know so South
breeze would know
Sotheby's would know and they would
check that the money is not from a
fishing place because they wouldn't sell
it they wouldn't let the buyer buy in
that case so because they have risk
right so we'll talk about it in a second
maybe right so these guys by the way
grappled with legal issues on the
day-to-day operation so I heard here's
the question I heard from somebody in
the day Israeli tax authority he said
you know we raided some guy he was
basically avoiding paying taxes we
seized a lot of his assets he had some
bitcoins now we're stuck with this legal
matter of should we keep the bitcoins
and give it to him if he's you know ever
exonerated in court or should we sell
them and give him the shekels all right
that sounds like a trivial thing he told
me you know if it's if it was a horse if
we you know seized the horse I'm
supposed to feed the horse I'm supposed
to take care of the horse so I don't
give him back you know the corpse of the
horse after 2 month
of trial or whatever or I can and I'm
not even allowed to Sarah Lee to sell
the horse I should give him back exactly
you know because it's a you know it's a
special horse it's unique you know a
breeder maybe and you can't buy another
replacement or you know if it's an art
piece of art so now with bitcoins where
they're worried about the volatility
because if later they're they're
supposed to give the monetary equivalent
maybe that's really changed by the time
they get there so the they're sitting
there grappling with these problems
which are not you know they're not
computer science problems but but still
they have to follow the letter of the
law so they you know is Bitcoin more
like a horse or is it more like dollars
so that that's why what bothers them yes
I think the volatility here is what
worries them they know how to handle
everything else and you know what you
know judgment on whether Bitcoin is you
know a commodity or or a currency affect
them in different ways not necessarily
just in text taxation but also after
they see something they need to know
what to do with it for stock they have
precedent but if you say bitcoin is like
stock that has other implications as
well I mean it's it's a risky thing to
declare you know bitcoins is our stock
then that means you tax them in a
certain way and that and and and that
has other implications if you're the tax
authority you know that court you'll
you'll have to explain your position at
some point
care which bitcoins right so the
fungibility of bitcoin is a very big
question as well well I will get and
I'll get to that so I probably won't
have time for it all the stuff I want to
show but we'll try so maybe I should say
you know what is what is the goal of
regulation it's you know with a
citizen's we often get annoyed by it but
but but but there are really good
reasons for for most of it it's always
to protect right the public from from
harm right if we think of pump and dump
manipulation inside trading or all of
the regulation in exchanges you know is
there you want to prevent criminal use
and terrorism finance right so money
shouldn't go to to Isis because we'd
like not to fund them there's a whole
branch of government that tries to lower
the systemic risk for the economy so
making sure that the banks are stable
that they're not over leveraged and so
on so maybe the first two are really
relevant to Bitcoin the the last one in
terms of systemic risk doesn't play a
big role because bitcoin is not very
widely used so so it doesn't represent
the systemic risk and everybody who's
kind of part of these discussions
recognizes that that at least right now
the volatility of Bitcoin is doesn't
affect a lot of stuff but but they do
for example prevent companies that deal
with Bitcoin from appearing in indexes
on you know like the S&P 500 and so on
you know the the so the Israeli
equivalents also they wouldn't have any
Bitcoin companies in them because
they're too volatile and they would make
the index move too much and indices are
actually you know traded through pension
funds and other things that you want to
keep stable so and and and maybe I
should say that there's also very big
motivation by all these guys they they
don't want to block technological
advancement they understand that this is
big they they are excited by
cryptocurrencies just like the general
public and they really don't want to
block it so maybe I I want to start
talking about different issues
specifically and I want to start with
taxation
so this is not regulation per se but the
taxation
I guess tax authorities were always the
first to to react to how how bitcoin is
handled and I think very similar to
other places Israeli tax authority is
pretty much the first to issue
guidelines in Israel guidelines are made
of fish alike in a 20-18
so not too long ago but there were other
you know preliminary suggestions before
that and there's active enforcement of
taxation on Bitcoin they literally send
out letters to people who have bought on
exchanges they get got lists of people
who traded on it on Israeli exchanges
and they all gotten letters kind of from
the you know Israeli tax authority to
report any trading that they've done and
just recently we had a court case that
reaffirms the status of a taxation on
bitcoins and maybe I should say that in
Bitcoin in Israel Bitcoin it is
considered an asset so what does it mean
that it's considered an asset it means
that you need to pay capital gains tax
on this asset okay right now so the
difference is if you took Israeli
shekels you traded two dollars you know
for your trip to the US then you five I
fly back to Israel I trade it back
chuckles maybe the dollar did something
change in value I don't need to pay
taxes for for relatively you know
reasonable amounts of foreign exchange
trade but if I buy bitcoins and sell
bitcoins and the exchange rate changed
even a little bit I owe the government
some percentage of capital gains tax
okay so that's a that's the decision
I've traded my shekels the US dollars
that you're not considered an asset no
not in Israel not for until you reach
really large amounts of you know high
trade volumes so you could be a Forex
train the trainer or like a huge one
then you you owe taxes I took ten
billion dollar shekels and made it into
three billion dollars in you that would
that would go over the amount but if you
did it with you know ten thousand
dollars you bought ten thousand dollars
and so tinta you know sold them on
on your you know a month later you made
a little bit of extra is based on the
size of the trade of the size of the
asset like so considered petty cash but
above two thousand or considered assets
for tax purposes yeah for capital gains
tax purposes I think so yeah you know
again I'm not an accountant or a lawyer
so take it with a grain of salt so the
idea is right it's very convenient to
trade money for money for foreign
exchange and you know there is some
fluctuation and we don't want to account
for everything as you see as you'll soon
see
having Bitcoin classified as an asset is
a real real pain in the neck right it's
gonna be horrible so this is all
cryptocurrencies basically everything so
you know it's more than just Bitcoin but
Bitcoin is the one that really matters
because that's what people most people
holding right no no I don't I don't
think so so so when you when you when
you press these guys you know what's the
rationale between you know it's it's not
a why is it not a currency why is it in
assets but that's different than a
currency and a foreign currency they
they say you know the letter of the law
is so-and-so but if you press them in
the US quote you know what's the
principle behind this forget forget the
letter of the law for a second and they
say you know the principle is you know
just in any tax you get wealthy for from
some activity you know you're you're a
citizen of this country you pay a little
bit to the state right and and and when
we say you get rich we really mean like
if you know if the value of the currency
changed because of inflation for example
we take that out you know profits are
only our inflation adjusted so so we
really see if you can buy more stuff
with your with your with your money
afterwards you got a little bit richer
you you need to allocate some some of it
to the state and when you press them on
why this is different from other foreign
currency they say usually you know you
we think this president of of foreign
currency not being taxed is wrong you
know this is where the mistake is
not in Bitcoin Bitcoin is done right but
they say you know we think the principle
was you know there was an interpretation
of some law and it was decided in some
court case but we think that was the
mistake so basically they want to say we
want to tax everything so you're only
your tax event is only for what profits
are kind of like on paper right so you
never realize them the same with stock
you hones on stock in the bank you don't
have to pay taxes at the end of the year
maybe you don't even have the money
everything like think of all my money
being in Bitcoin know if I want to buy
something we stock I first have to sell
the stock yes but that's then is a
considered by by the tax authorities to
be barter so if I for example come to a
store and I barter apples for milk or
something like that the the way the
accounting is done is they think of the
sell sale of apples to the currency
right shekels in Israel for some price
and then I bought milk with that so it's
always an activity if you if you check
if you trade your bitcoins for something
you basically just sold them and maybe
you bought something else at the same
time
yes so I'm gonna exactly talk about that
and that leads to some ridiculous
conclusions right so exactly buying
something with Bitcoin is a tax event
right you you you owe taxes capital
gains tax when you sell because of
course depending on whether you made a
profit if you actually if you made the
loss you can actually get money from the
state you can offset that with the other
games that you made in a in other stock
or or other places and that really makes
it super hard to keep track and report
all activity every time you go to the
grocery store with bitcoins and you you
want to pay you buy milk right you have
a tax event and you need to figure out
how much tax you need to pay right so so
if you think about it if you want to
manage that that's gonna need the
software on both sides right your side
for keeping tally you know track of when
you sold every Bitcoin you had maybe a
cross multiple wallets and the tax
authority when you give them a report of
like a million transactions that you've
done in the last year their needs
they're gonna need to check it out so
they need software in there and so
that's again a technological barrier you
know they probably can't have you report
it right now if they want it and we
should always remember that Bitcoin goes
up a lot in cryptocurrencies but they
also crash so losses can can actually be
offset against other taxation in the
future so you can actually roll buses
over to that like next year next year's
taxes and get a reduction in taxes for
the future year where there's no
official transaction record then it's
not so so even in Bitcoin you nobody
uses the official transaction record if
you think about other goods like stocks
are being traded they don't go to the
official record unless they are
investigating you you basically declare
something so enlightening you would
presumably need to need to declare but
you're right how do you verify something
at all right you know in a lightening
shadow in a lighting channel you're
giving away or receiving right if you're
transacting if you're an intermediate
node you're not doing anything except
maybe you're getting fees
me though and I send you basically a
signature that you can execute so in
other words I'm giving you an option as
opposed to an actual center so for
lightening I would ask when is the point
in time at which we actually transfer
the money is it when you will when we
close the channel but what if I you know
I can close I can close any channel on
on empty by by pushing stuff to like two
other channels right so you could
shuffle money within the lightning
Network in this way so that would does
that postpone the tax event and this
this has implications for you know tax
planning for example so this is this is
something that you know people in Israel
really didn't like because you know just
it kills the use of Bitcoin as a main
means of payment just by this
declaration makes it really hard to use
people like let's say I inherit like all
the people who know like they can't sell
that stuff but they often like you know
skirt these capital gains taxes by just
borrowing against an asset and then you
know having a technically a debt and
then basically spending from that debt
so I mean maybe that's the right way to
think about this stuff - yeah I don't
know I mean this is more aggressive tax
planning that I'm sure you know some
accountants can make a field day out of
all this stuff and and and I'll link to
some some of these days so maybe I
should also tell you about this is
something that I found out about about
people taxation yeah
existing framework that said the
understanding so but somebody else they
spend some cycles thinking about like
where how does this aspiration of not
you advancement for that person how does
it manifest it looks like these are all
bad implications there is no good
implication maybe there are some of the
things that are saying you know we have
to abide by the law this is how we
interpret the law and then they say you
know we can initiate one of the things
they've done in Israel recently is a
regulatory sandbox so you can apply to
the government to get exemption from a
lot of regulation and get access to
information from the stock exchange and
so on
and you can run your financial
experiments within the sandbox to kind
of seen how it goes
so they're also encouraging a
cryptocurrency companies to do that but
but I should tell you know you know
things like taxation that's not a that's
not a regulatory thing this is not
something that they're gonna budge on I
mean they see people get rich very rich
and they say you know the government
gets cut this is what it means to live
in a in a modern society now the exact
way you're supposed to get take that cut
is maybe an issue but somehow there's an
exemption for dollars but then the issue
never comes up because the dollar
doesn't fluctuate as much as Bitcoin
nobody you know some people make a lot
of money from foreign exchange usually
they're over the bar for getting taxed
on it anyway so so that question
practically doesn't come up so much
whereas it would Bitcoin you know people
made millions and millions and to be
honest I you know I think it's fair you
know I'm a taxpaying citizen I would
like to see people pay taxes in general
right so maybe I should I want to switch
over to three for taxation show so when
you sell a Bitcoin right we need to
figure out what the tax is
and so we need to figure out you know
how much did you buy that Bitcoin for so
what happens with stock and this is also
porn it be imported to two bitcoins is
that the Bitcoin that you sell first is
the one that you bought first if you
have a stash of bitcoins you bought them
at different times the one that you sell
first is the one that you bought first
so it's before so it's interesting to
see that accountants know some computer
science terms and this leads to some
really extreme examples this is a these
are true stories there are people in
Israel that have had this happen to them
so some Joe Smith maybe bought a Bitcoin
for you know four thousand dollars in in
2017 there was a time when it was worth
four thousand dollars and he holds it
for a while and then you know Bitcoin
spikes up to twenty thousand dollars
early 2018 or late 2017 and he wants to
buy some other cryptocurrency maybe
those going but you know dogecoin
doesn't get traded on Israeli exchanges
so what he does is he buys a Bitcoin for
$20,000 and converts that Bitcoin to
dogecoin because that's the only way you
can buy those coin and now Bitcoin
crashes back to four thousand dollars
and you know poor Joe just learns that
he owes taxes because the taxation on on
Bitcoin was really formalized only late
January I think mid January of 2018 so
after this happened so now why does he
owe taxes because he converted Bitcoin
to dodge going that's a barter exchange
so he basically sold the Bitcoin he saw
the Bitcoin at twenty thousand dollars
but it's not the Bitcoin that he just
bought at twenty thousand dollars
because of the FIFA rule this Bitcoin
that he's are sold is the one that he
bought for $4,000 so he's sixteen
thousand dollars in profit and I think
he owes 25 percent of that to the
government so he owes four thousand
dollars basically you know the Bitcoin
that he has the one bit on that he had
hope he's worth four thousand dollars
and that's the amount of tax that he now
owns the cut the government right it you
could set it up so that he owes more
money than he has
very easily because he wasn't aware that
there was a tax event here so of course
this is just this isn't it you know this
is a maybe a single current event
because after these regulations get get
get published you know he should know
better and and you should you should be
taxed but there are some people who are
stuck with taxes for money that they
don't have loss of sixteen thousand
right now yeah yeah so you're right he
does he does have a lot here he does
have a loss but so somewhat what
happened really is that some people
started you know they they were doing
trades right so they're trading trading
trading training so they they bought
some bitcoins and then they maybe change
all of them to dosh right he could have
done that as well
instead of buying an extra Bitcoin and
buy by trading and then having
everything crash just the trades at that
point in time may have may have keep may
have killed a lot of a lot of profits
now not everything moves the same right
those con does not necessarily make the
loss that Bitcoin made these gains so
there we are we have situations where
people are stuck like this change from
one Bitcoin to have her many dogecoin
why is there like a nice energetic
bartered bitcoins because bitcoins are
not considered a currency so what what
he just did is but it's like exchanging
apples for milk so the way to account
for this is to consider the bitcoins as
sold in you know in shackles in this
case you know dollars in this example
and then you purchase with with that the
dogecoin so that's how the accounting is
done and that's a tax event well there
you have it this is not theoretical in
this happen to me
that's even worse because you can have
this enormous tax bill that you have to
pay now and even if you have this latent
laws it's in a different tax ear and so
that loss now can only be carry right
word right you owe the government you
know hundreds of thousands of dollars or
whatever it is you don't have any money
pay it and the loss that offsets it only
counts right may or may not occur
exactly that's the same in Israel losses
are you cannot cover past say against
can abstract it as just maybe
dealing with highly volatile like assets
and maybe just right so I think that
that is that would cover the case and
also I will admit that it is the one
time thing because there was unclear it
wasn't clear how to pay taxes when this
they were doing these trades and then we
stocks you know maybe the bank would
even or would even tell you right if
you're trading on some you know you
through some intermediary maybe they
would tell you you know you you're in
trouble here you owe taxes but
definitely you need to know what you're
doing and and you're right
volatile assets are problematic and
people are asking you know why can't I
pay my taxes in bitcoins if I could take
pay I paid my taxes in bitcoins maybe
that that would make sense but that's
not true
currencies have value because you know
your contracts say that you know you you
you get them as salaries for example so
there's a demand by your employers to
get the currency so they can pay
salaries so that that gives it inherent
value and and also you know to buy goods
so one interesting kind of valid goes on
behind the scenes that I'm not up to
date on where exactly that is you know
if you are selling as stocks at banks
the bank actually with holds taxes
automatically they figure out what a the
gains are from when you bought the the
stock and and they and they tax you and
now what the authorities want is they
want the Israeli exchanges to also
withhold taxes automatically on on on
gains so if you go and you buy some
bitcoins and exit an exchange and then
sell it you're supposed to pay taxes
this is super super problematic for the
exchanges so if you think about it in
conjunction with the FIFO rule right
let's say I bought bit
in exchange then I went to a different
place and bought some bitcoins and I'm
selling something
so which bitcoins am i selling the fee
for rule says me I may not be selling
the bitcoins that the exchange has
actually seen I'm selling some other
Bitcoin that was purchased elsewhere at
a different point in time so how do you
tax it
you need some declaration from the you
know the person selling about what bit
about all their bitcoins holding over
time so you can figure out what what the
FIFA will actually says and this is this
is getting to be a problem I mean in
Israel in Israel there's a thing in
Hebrew you know go prove you don't have
a sister something that's hard to show
like go show that you didn't buy other
Bitcoin somewhere in the middle that you
are actually supposed to be taxed for
you know we can buy anonymously on other
wallets so how do we do that that's
that's a big problem so that so right
now there's a lot of a kind of lobbying
in back and forth between the exchanges
and Israeli authorities on how to do
this and and you know for for Israelis
this is you know this would take care of
you know if you if you do something by
default it takes care of a lot of the
population
you know Israeli taxes for example are
usually we'd head for like the majority
of the population who are employed
somewhere and they don't need to
interact with the authorities at all
there's no tax reporting done at the end
of the year for most most people so this
is about taxation like is that because
people as well yeah that's basically how
long do I have
oh my gosh okay then let me skip the
position and I cos I want to go to anti
money laundering and anti-terrorism
finance just to talk about that so this
is I think is the other very interesting
topic banks are super risk-averse and
they don't allow you know others to have
you know people to have bank accounts
yeah so not so so you can only have
downside with AML I mean what can happen
is your thought is show up and they slap
your big fine and they tell you you know
you've you've helped some some guy
launder money so they they're supposed
to manage their own risk so here's a
story about the guy he revealed his name
on in the paper his name is Ron gross
he's one of the early Bitcoin
enthusiasts in Israel and he was
basically asking the tax authorities to
pay taxes on his gains he wanted to pay
taxes he has his money in Switzerland in
a bank account that he's you know he saw
these bitcoins it's in Switzerland and
he can't pay the tax authorities he
can't transfer money to the tax
authorities they would not accept a
transfer from Switzerland in dollars
that's not allowed you have to give them
shekels he can't get his money into an
Israeli bank because it comes from
Bitcoin and they don't want to give him
a bank account so he's stuck and
basically they seized his scooter and he
in his apartment and his bank account in
shekels he doesn't have enough money in
it to cover the taxes that he owes right
so the the end and everybody's really
sympathetic and they say you know we
understand your plight but but this is
what what you know this is the state of
things we're not allowed to touch this
this stuff so he couldn't pay taxes for
a while
UBS won't let him go to the counter and
say you could probably you know get it
in cash but then you go to an Israeli
bank he tried to deposit this cash
though asking where's this money from
you'll have to say this is from sale of
bitcoins you know you cannot pay your
taxes in cash as well there was an app
there was another story in the paper not
too not too long ago about the guy who
was a hiding cash in the walls of this
house from from from it from basically
who's hiding you know he had a ran a
cash-only business and it was
misreporting on taxes and he wanted to
settle with authorities he wanted to
kind of pay back what he's his dues and
he went to a lawyer and he negotiated
the deal with the tax Israeli tax
authority to pay the cash
and then he said you know I have all
this cash they said we can't accept cash
were not allowed to we were only allowed
to accept transfer so he went to the
bank with his you know large stack of
cash and said I wanted to posit this to
give it to the Israeli Revenue Service
and they wouldn't allow it because they
don't know where the source of the cash
is maybe it's a drug trade or something
they don't know so he ended up working
out a deal with the tax authorities
they're only allowed to take cash if
they seize it in in their one of their
operations so he said you know you come
to my house at 12 o'clock I'm gonna put
a large stack of cash on my table and
you can seize it and they agreed to that
and eventually they even agreed to let
him come into their offices and give him
you know with the cash and they'll seize
it right there because they didn't want
to go all the way to his house so so
eventually they found a loophole that
allowed them to take cash so this is a
true story so so this is not just
Bitcoin this is you know how government
works if you find that funny you know so
like this is why it gets into the paper
it's excellent clickbait so this is not
just Israel I mean maybe I should say
right III also had the so I want to
address that in a second okay I'll kind
of give the lay of the land so there's a
there are some court cases that are
related the in Israeli currency exchange
bits of gold has won a legal victory
over an Israeli bank to keep access to
banking services banks are basically
state-issued oligopolies right there the
government says you can't be a bank
unless you get certain permits and that
comes with some liabilities you you have
to serve everyone by law you know the
law says you have to give everybody
services and so these guys wanted to run
in you know a Bitcoin exchange or you
know you know sell and buy bitcoins and
so they'd have to give them a bank
account they really had a lot of trouble
and this was a very important court case
there's also a mining company company
who is doing mining through mining
contracts who wanted to get their money
from bit you know
converted into into shekels it was maybe
the cleanest case you could you could
ever have because you could see on the
Bitcoin blockchain that this is not
money that came from some source other
than mining so it's literally currency
that was just minted by miners and they
wanted to cash it out and get paid for
it in shekels and the bank didn't allow
them to have an account and block their
transaction and the judge eventually
said that they have to have a bank
account the bank has to supply that but
he can see the bank and still block
specific payments including that payment
if they want because these guys weren't
really forthcoming the light there or
held held back a little bit of
information but what they were doing
that's fine but this wasn't about
taxation so so the reason banks are
shutting down these activities because
of of money laundering issues and money
laundering in Israel at least is is
decided by by actually an international
body called the eff ATF the Financial
Action Task Force which is a body that
kind of has I think 30 something maybe
40 up to close to 40 s in member
countries and they kind of decide
together on laws for compliance with
with anti-terrorism finance and money
laundering and then once they decide
everybody every country has to pass
these laws into into its into its rules
and and and then they get peer reviewed
by other countries for compliance did
they actually do what's supposed to
happen so this is what you know their
assembly looks like a lot of kind of a
UN style meeting where a lot of
countries get together and discuss this
stuff and what happened is that the eff
ATF recently said how to handle
cryptocurrencies so this is the
Financial Action Task Force basically
this
defines something called a vasp which is
a virtual asset
service provider and vests are actually
regulated entities so exchanges now fall
under regulation according to the FAA PF
and Israel is also adopting this that
means that every time bitcoins pass from
an exchange from a regulated entity to a
regulated entity and exchange to an
exchange or an exchange to a bank they
are required to share customer details
about whose money it is that they're
transferring this is the same as what
happens with with dollars and otherwise
if you're an unregulated entity you're
not a vasp then your bitcoins are
basically considered to be cash so it's
like money that we you know we don't
know where it came from
it it's anonymous you know whether you
can or cannot track it on the Bitcoin
blockchain you know we don't know so so
whoever is accepting this money has to
now decide if they're willing to take
the risk for AML the risk that they
later gets fine for for you know
allowing money-laundering to occur so so
maybe I should show this so so this is
how currency regulation goes if you're
like on one side of the fence you have
banks that are regulated you know they
send money to each other that could be
dollars not necessarily bitcoins and on
the other side of the fence you have you
know regular cash and you have bitcoins
that that are considered pretty much as
cash and it used to be that Bitcoin
exchanges were on this side of the fence
they weren't regulated so every time you
try to send money from here to here you
had to really explain where it came from
and you know it's it's it was very hard
to prove so now what what's gonna happen
is f ATF regulation basically moves the
fence you know the fence is gonna be
here these guys are now regulated if you
take money out to your Bitcoin wallet
and then deposit it again into an
exchange you're gonna have to explain
what happened and where it came from
what is the source of the funds just as
if you did it with cash so for small
amounts that wouldn't be a problem but
if you come up with something like
$10,000 they're gonna start asking
questions if you ever like sell a car
and show up with a wad of
- that they immediately want to see
papers that you've actually sold
something where this come from and how
this happened
right so so that's basically ETF is
international so so these doesn't have
to be banks in Israel there's gonna be
banks like Switzerland in the US and so
on like if I transfer from an account in
the US on my name to an Israeli account
at my name then you know I wouldn't have
a problem with the transfer they send my
details I don't I don't even get asked
questions that's the usual case so now
what really happens is exchanges are
going to have an easier time sending
money to banks but now they're gonna be
under the microscope in terms of you
know what what they allow in so this
regulatory influence that used to be
like the door doorway of banks is now on
the exchanges they need to suddenly
develop this infrastructure that they
don't have to figure out where bitcoins
come from and that this travel rule that
says you have to share details of the
person sending the money means that if
money is sent from coinbase to buy to
another European exchange they need to
recognize this Bitcoin transfer as one
occurring between regulated bodies and
they have to send over customer details
so the Bitcoin protocol isn't built for
that right if you get money from
somewhere you don't know that came from
the coin base there's no way to tell
right now but they are legally obligated
now to know right so they have to know
if you send if you are a vast when you
get you're getting money from another
vast you need to know customer details
so that's another place where technology
can potentially solve it but it's not
there I mean I don't know how they're
gonna do this
existence is probably not going to ever
be secure anyways it's just provided as
information for your eminence
so yeah so so actually right now you're
doing Swift transfer Swift transfer does
is only data and it does carry you in
the message where you are sending money
it carries your details so the F ATF
understood that the Bitcoin protocol
doesn't have the metadata in the
transaction itself so they made a
special allowance that the metadata
could go through another system that's
fine that's okay as long as it goes
through but but you need to recognize
this right so now coinbase if it gets a
Bitcoin payment it needs to know if it
came from another regulated body to be
able to end to be able to [ __ ] to
somehow receive on on some system that
doesn't yet exist the corresponding
metadata to that transaction that's a
big problem I don't know so those are F
ATF regulations right now there's the
travel rule that applied for Swift
transfers now applies to Bitcoin
transfer between regulated bodies and
exchanges are regulated bodies so I
think I ran out of time so maybe I will
just kind of say there's there's a lot
of places where science you know kind of
modern science starts to challenge
regulation one one very big trend that
goes on is that there's instead of more
privacy
you know eff ATF and other authorities
are actually going the other direction
they're going into big data analysis in
data pools and revealing everything and
sharing data between member countries so
this is a an interesting trend they're
completely ignoring traces on the
blockchain so maybe there's a missed
opportunity there they're thinking of
Bitcoin is cash that is anonymous maybe
you can learn something from the
blockchain it's not clear what to what
you could learn I think there's a missed
opportunity
there that you could actually abide by
things like the travel rule if you kind
of pre-register your own your own wallet
and so on
you obviously like
really challenges regulation again you
could launder money very easily because
of you know liking payments are
anonymized react or like or routing so
you if you're an intermediate node you
don't know where you where it's coming
where it's going and if you start to
think about things like zero knowledge
proof and you know what happens if
you're not in exchange that just holds
money or you your Asha you know you do
some Shamir secret sharing to distribute
keys and you do multi-party computation
protocols to sign transfers so are you
again a regulated entity and how do you
comply and you know so all of these
things are gonna run a challenge
regulation I don't see how how its gonna
cope exactly
but right now what we're seeing is an
application of current rules just being
extended to Bitcoin
so sometimes it's natural and sometimes
it's really not natural right and that's
that may be the big issue so I guess
I'll stop here and thank you all
[Applause]
what chance a bit wanna know if Libra is
big and does the deal with the regulator
the regulator will consider Libra as a
currency and then no Libra is gonna have
every single problem that you know other
cryptocurrencies are having they're not
there every indication is that they're
not getting a free pass from regulators
right if and if they do set precedents
that's fine that that would make a
difference in some things but you know
for for AML for example anti money
laundering if libera libera claims that
they want to give you know to help the
unbanked right who are these unbanked
there are people in the in third-world
countries that you you know don't have
really strong identities maybe don't
have strong banking systems it's very
easy to launder money if you you know
you're in such a setting and to create
false identities and frank accounts and
Libra is gonna have a very big challenge
convincing regulators that money
laundering isn't going going on through
this and you know terrorism financing
isn't going through the system so it's
it's good I think if you look for a
challenge in Libra it's not going to be
the technical challenge this is gonna be
easy the regulatory challenges is gonna
is gonna be the hard thing that's my
that's Sam I guess we can ask there's a
neo just after noon speakers from Libra
so you're probably asking what about
that yeah
perfect money-laundering opportunities
you get completely fresh points there's
no way to connect them to anything else
and so how do you deal with this like I
think that's very easy actually in
practice because if you think of
somebody running you know a cash-only
business you know he can launder money
just as well right well so how do you
audit him but you're minors you can ask
him just you know show me or you know
you're mining equipment show me or get
you know your your electricity bills
show me that you've been running this
thing like my name would mean in a
country that it's not part of this 40 I
keep it in the sea in the middle of the
ocean on the ship with like ya know
basically this really relies on the
knowledge ability to say that no these
coins are good and these coins are not
if I have a system where the mining is
it's not about the non fungibility
you're gonna have in a you know payment
going into an exchange it doesn't matter
you could have changed it to you know
with somebody else's money
bitcoins right so you get fresh bitcoins
from somebody who mined in Israel give
them to you directly
you know he tells you even gives you the
keys so there's no transfer on the
blockchain and you're gonna now send it
into a bank so now you need to explain
where did it come from
now you know how did you come upon this
you know 1 million dollars worth of
bitcoins and and you're gonna have to
provide documentation for for where it
came and this is not different than
what's going on right now I mean if you
show up with a suitcase full of you know
dot $1 and you say I wanted to posit
this they're gonna ask you a lot of
questions right and sometimes they're
not they're not going to accept your
money that's that's part of it so it's
not if it comes from a well-known source
you know you you're gonna say you know
I'm you know I'm Walmart and I had these
sales and if you know this is transfer
from a European Bank to a u.s. bank or
whatever they're they're gonna say fine
you know we know where you how you made
this money you know where it came we
know it came from the place that came
from is also regulated so if we want to
invest
to get you we you know we go to Interpol
or something and and we ask you know we
get a court order to see the records
they they they know who you are and we
can trace the money back in terms of
identities so this is something that
actually they were really adamant about
when I asked them you know what what if
I show you traces on a Bitcoin
blockchain I mean it can't lie they
basically said we want the ability to
investigate people without their
knowledge so you if you go to Z cache
for example you could always comply you
could give maybe cryptographic evidence
of where the money came from you know
signatures and so you can construct
systems that would still be anonymous
unless you voluntarily you know reveal
everything and then they can you know
give you a court order and or you want
to comply and you can show them
everything but they want the ability to
investigate you without your knowledge
without your compliance that means they
have to have you know either the data
somewhere in the clear or you know
backdoors or keys that are them to see
everything anyway so so I think this is
a big societal question of how we handle
privacy and you know state surveillance
and you know is this they are gonna leak
and this is if you ask them you know
they're the enforcers obviously their
job is always to catch criminals so they
want access to more and more tools they
don't think that they're doing something
bad on the other hand we need to push
back and maybe say you know we don't
want to give you all this information
and maybe you shouldn't be able to
investigate people without them knowing
this
zero zero knowledge proof that a Texas
this is something ask Ellie and you get
I can send zero knowledge proof I love
you so think of bitcoins think of
Bitcoin zero knowledge proof saying you
know here's you know I owned Bitcoin I
now solve Bitcoin you know here's this
proof that it is on the on the bit on
the Bitcoin ledger with you know it's on
miracle trees so you can prove it this
Bitcoin actually came from another
address and I have a signature
you know attesting that you know this
address is in exchange for example now
you can verify this computation but
maybe I can prove to you without showing
you the records I can just tell you you
know what this bitcoins that I sold I
actually bought it here without you
without no telling you what here is and
how many I bought it just I you know I
owe you so on so many taxes that's a
computation that you do to verify the
correctness of that computation it's
computation yeah paying taxes is a
computation right there's usually an
excel sheet but it's still computation
computational you were computer
scientists after the break there'll be
workshop we're gonna have the workshop
here or upstairs